welcome back to this special edition of
hannity now let's turn back to the
crisis at the southern border
will kamala's big trip to el paso
actually improve
anything joining us now is former rice
director and fox news contributor tom
homan all right tom looks like you're
standing in front of the wall
back there what have you seen today
well i'm i'm right outside of sierra
vista arizona i'm down here on the
border wall because walls work
something come out of harris don't
understand but i'm here with what i'm
seeing
is is the men and women that make up
this community are angry because
this this country's in trouble right
because the borders are in chaos
i'm here with about a hundred sheriffs
and sheriffs are making a point this
isn't just about illegal immigration
i talked to one sheriff already found 42
dead migrants
within this county that put themselves
in the hands of criminal cartels make
this trip
they're talking about the high-speed
chases the amount of fentanyl coming
across this border that killing
americans
i'm here with angel moms and dads whose
children were murdered by illegal aliens
which wouldn't happen if we had a wall
and had better security other moms and
dads who lost their children to fentanyl
overdoses that wouldn't happen if we had
border security so the fentanyl could
come across
with a border crisis like it is jess we
talked about it before when half of the
board which was tied up with families
and children
that's when the car tells you get the
gang members in here that's when they
get the drugs in here
and that's why the sheriffs are having
such a huge problem down there a story
is not being told
is a violence the sheriffs are dealing
with all along the southwest border
just like what you've seen with the
defund the police situation
tom are we going to get to the point
where you're going to see mass
retirements among
law enforcement on the border and border
patrol agents
i don't think so cause the board told us
american patriots i started my career
sports relations
they're angry and they have zero respect
in the president zero respecting the
uh and the secretary of homeland
security but i think they're gonna keep
doing their job
and you i heard you mentioned about
kamala harris that i'll pass the border
today
what a shame she should have been
embarrassed she's going to go down there
and see the men and women
who she called nazis she's going to see
the men and women
she said run concentration camps she she
claimed the border patrol treated these
illegal immigrants
with with zero compassion and humanity
and one thing she didn't do while she
was down there
why don't you talk to the men and women
wearing their green uniform ask him does
the wall work and they would have said
yes it does work it stops drugs to stop
dealing with immigration why did you
stop building it
and she would have said why we had a
crisis they would have told her because
of your policies your open border
policies we had success
president trump dropped immigration by
80 percent
how many children didn't die across that
river how many women didn't get raped
coming across that border how many
children didn't die of over
fentanyl overdoses how many millions did
the cartels not make
when the president trump had 80
declining immigration
this president has failed american
people we have the first president in
the history of this nation
that's actively facilitating illegal
immigration across border crime and it
disgusts me
all right tom i couldn't say it better
myself thank you so much we appreciate
it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else